and on the stand the woman from Planned
Parenthood was talking about this and
that one of the legislators said but
what about keeping abortion safe right
isn't that what you said you want and
she said no it's now about access so
it's really about access at all costs so
even if the woman is killed even if
she's hurt even if she believes adapt on
the table and least she had access to
abortion all right very glad to have our
next guest here this is a long form
today and we do it every now and then
with just some guests who I just you
know what I don't need to justify myself
to you I want to talk with this lady for
a longer round of time she hasn't been
on the show I don't think I don't think
three years she had been on the show
back when I was in my den before it was
daily you can follow her on the Twitter
at Abby Johnson she's a former Planned
Parenthood worker author she has website
Abby Johnson org abortion worker calm
we'll be talking about that quite a bit
today and a movie coming out unplanned
film calm Abby Johnson thank you for
being here thank you for having me well
I'm glad to have you back you look you
look bright I didn't bushy-tailed I hope
you're in you're in good health good
spirits
you know I'm pregnant so I have the
pregnant glow I think oh isn't it ironic
like a lamp back here that sort of gives
me like the Trump glow so it really am
so long as it's not a UV lamp because of
the pregnancy but we're fine either way
it's all a good thing for people who
don't know and we've had you on the show
before but I think a lot of people will
be someone across this this program here
on YouTube might necessarily know your
background you worked at Planned
Parenthood left and wrote about it I
don't want to speak for you give them
kind of a recap yes I worked at Planned
Parenthood for eight years I was a
clinic director at one of the affiliate
facilities out of Houston got involved
as a college kid didn't know much about
playing parent and really got involved
with them loved what I was doing
believed we were doing the right things
in 2009 we were building it's now in
operation the largest abortion facility
in the Western Hemisphere we were
building a facility abortion facility
that would abort baby
through 24 weeks pregnancy for any any
reason that was problematic for me
because I knew we were now like in the
point of viability for babies
few months later I had a meeting with my
supervisor where I was instructed to
double our abortion quota the number of
abortions that we had to sell to women
coming in and then a few months later I
was asked to come in and assist during
an ultrasound guided abortion procedure
ultrasounds are not typically used
during the actual abortion procedure
they're used before so that you can date
the pregnancy so that you know how much
to charge the woman for an abortion
ultrasounds are rolled away and the
abortion itself is actually done in a
blind sort of manner so that's very
important obviously it is important to
those in the left they've talked about
not wanting women to see ultrasounds or
not wanting to have to look at
ultrasounds before performing an
abortion which to me would seem like a
reasonable policy before we continue
with that I think I do want to touch on
that because it's extremely relevant
given what just happened in New York the
reproductive health act just passed for
people who don't know I think the bill
actually Broad's this this if I'm not
mistaken a health exception for
abortions up to as you just mentioned 24
weeks that's that's up to 9 months of
pregnancy for age economic social
there's a list on the website do I have
that about right so you can have an
abortion for any reason up until 24
weeks which is six months of pregnancy
and then after 24 weeks so from 25 to 40
weeks so you know the date of birth
right um you could have an abortion for
basically anything because they quantify
it as health of the mother which can
literally be anything so right if I'm
feeling stressed that is impeding my
health right if I'm feeling anxious
that's a reason if my boyfriend ran out
on me certainly that's causing the
emotional distress so that's reason so
you can now kill a baby through the date
of birth in the state of me
right so abortions up to 24 weeks with
broad health exceptions up to birth it's
like a medical marijuana card killing
babies I got back pain give me pot it's
like I got back pain kill the baby
pretty much yeah exactly and you're
there already some states that have this
exception one of the things that makes
New York a little bit different so
California I mean Colorado allows no
surprise but Colorado allows abortion up
until the date of birth as well one of
the differences though with the New York
law is that now it's expanded so that it
doesn't have to be physicians actually
performing the abortion which is similar
to what we saw in California so in
California nurses can now perform
abortions on women it's now the same in
New York so we don't even have
physicians performing these abortions on
women who come in anymore that seems
we're moving away from safe legal and
rare right they said if you don't have
this legal and available to everyone
will be doing back-alley abortions with
coat hangers and now they're saying well
you know it's legal but a nurse
practitioner is good enough so we saw
that in California specifically so few
years ago when that when that bill
passed and through the legislature
Planned Parenthood had actually done a
pilot study with nurses performing
abortions and what they had found no
surprise and this is not to diss on
nurses because I love love love nurses
but they are not as skilled in
performing surgical procedures right
they're not trying to perform surgeries
when they're going through school so
what they found what Planned Parenthood
found in their pilot study was that
there was an increased risk of
hysterectomy
on women who had abortions performed by
nurses increased risk of infection
because of fetal products still left in
the womb there were all these
complications increased risk of uterine
perforation and on the stand the woman
from Planned Parenthood was talking
about this and that one of the
legislators said but what about keeping
abortions safe right isn't that what you
said you want and she said no it's now
about access so it's really about access
at all costs so even if the woman is
killed even if she's hurt even if she
believes it back on the table and
she had access to abortion right and I
understand that you're not dissing on
nurses but I will for a couple of
minutes here I just had a nurse hook up
an IV and prep miss the vein the first
time and then the second time missed it
to the point where I had to be holding
it and the doctor came in redid it I had
to be holding this thing at the right
angle for about an hour and my arms he
got it was swollen like the head of the
guy from the Goonies for about half a
day when I had to sit there in Nevada so
yeah I you know I don't I don't when I'm
at a restaurant and they say hi this is
my shadow or apprentice a server like do
you mind if she or he takes your orders
today I say I do send them away
I want the best server humanly possible
right now because I don't want you to
risk bringing my sidecar out with too
much Cointreau that's how that's how
strict that when it would come to
abortion it seems as though to me for
talking about safe legal and rare if
we're talking about wanting to increase
I hate use the word quality or safety or
health standards of abortion that this
would fly in the face of what so-called
feminists have fought for for years for
sure and we actually through my ministry
we just it's really not part of our
mission but we say our mission is
mission drift we started looking at
inspection reports from abortion
facilities so inspection reports that
come from the state we took all of them
together we got them through FOIA is in
each state we put them all together on a
website people can go it's called check
my clinic org and you can see Planned
Parenthood clinics individual clinics
they're not sterilizing instruments that
are being used woman-to-woman some of
these clinics why not though what why
not i mean i-i sterilized a needle if i
have a hangnail
why don't they it seems that that would
be pretty easy there's no time so you've
got many abortions they can't sterilize
equipment yeah well it takes about 45
minutes for a full auto claim cycle to
run okay so most clinics have about 20
packs of instruments and a lot of
clinics are performing 50 60 70 abortion
today so you don't have time to continue
to run the packs so some of the clinics
are watching the instruments in Dawn
dish soap
and saying that that sanitary enough to
put inside another woman there was a
clinic that had rat holes where they
could see rats coming in and out of the
building and this is where the abortions
were actually taking place why is it
this secular feminist movement up in
arms saying this is bad for women it
doesn't mean it doesn't make any sense
okay couple things did you just say dawn
because of a nut mistake and I've seen
commercials saying gentle enough to use
on this duck a victim of the BP oil
spill I want some kind of solvent that
would strip the varnish off a footlocker
when it comes to performing abortions
second I have to argue on behalf I guess
have left us who wouldn't be here who
say you're taking extreme examples to
make a point this is not common what
would there be some validity to that
claim for them it's so if they go to the
website you can look at almost every
single abortion facility has these types
of egregious violations on their
inspection reports and I mean we didn't
make it up it's it's from the state
reports people can see the official
state report right there it's crazy it's
crazy what they're getting away with
like if a hospital was doing this they
would be shut down
are there lower standards of care for
abortion clinics and hospitals I guess
that's the laser question there are
there lower standards of care and health
and in how sanitary these conditions can
be when compared to a hospital yes
absolutely
that's deeply concerning and it would be
deeply concerning to someone who is
pro-abortion
they kind of like I bring it back to the
people who talk about legalizing pot you
know in California now a lot of them
still want to buy their potty illegally
because turns out taxes are expensive
but yeah now you know there are no
contaminants you know where it's grown
and you know the concentration like yeah
but it's like three times the price and
so I'm gonna go buy something called
og dream from a guy named little cuz let
me ask you this another guy know his
stuff was actually it may it may not be
fda-approved well they're not
fda-approved Manette be state approved
but he knows what he's doing I will say
that hydro plant that guy knows what
he's doing is a greenhouse in his
walk-in closet let me ask you this
Planned Parenthood okay because I want
to get into
your ministry your outreach that you do
right now I also want to get into your
experience with having been both to the
women's March and speaking at the March
for Life which was at the center of
quite a bit of controversy recently my
wife works at a price at crisis a crisis
pregnancy center and of course options
counseling they help women with how to
take care of the baby prenatal vitamins
if they want to give the child up for
adoption if they are going to be a
single mother nannying care let me
assisted Planned Parenthood because
we're told they offer a whole lot more
than abortion I think that's something
that is often missed by people who
haven't gone through the process or
people who don't work specifically in
the abortion or unplanned planned
pregnancy arena were there options
counseling offered at Planned Parenthood
is that a part of their business plan
there no not at all we when I was
trained to to you know be a counselor at
Planned Parenthood and in counseled
women who were coming in to have
abortions I was told not to introduce
other options to them because women who
come into Planned Parenthood know that
they want an abortion so we do not want
to confuse them by giving them other
options they're here they came to
Planned Parenthood they know what they
want they want an abortion when I
graduated with my master's degree in
therapy I noticed that on all of our
documentation it said that we provided
options counseling and I knew that
wasn't true so I said look you know we
should actually do this if we're going
to say we do it we should we should do
it
so I write up this protocol to you know
how to provide professional options
counseling to women who come in who are
pregnant I send it off to PPF a
Federation of American Federation
America I get a letter back from them
that says they are rejecting my protocol
because they do not find it to be
revenue generating so what does that
mean if a woman decides to choose life
and decides to carry the pregnancy to
term well Planned Parenthood isn't
provide prenatal care so we can't make
money off of the woman choosing to keep
her child if a woman places her child
for adoption we don't get any adoption
kickback for that
so to give her options counseling if she
chooses another option outside of
abortion that's not revenue-generating
for Planned Parenthood but such a small
percentage of the revenue generated at
Planned Parenthood is from abortions I'm
told Abby you have the floor yeah but we
see in their annual report about 50%
their revenue generated comes from
abortion procedures about the other
about 50% comes from comes from
government money comes from our tax
dollars so they say it's such a tiny
little percentage of what they do yet it
makes up half of their revenue how does
that happen and well it doesn't so last
time you blamed yeah they they add up
these different services which are
clearly being performed for the abortion
but they they separate them as line
items right so what they do so if I go
in to Planned Parenthood and I'm gonna
get my annual exam right I'm gonna get a
pap smear I'm gonna get a gonorrhea and
chlamydia tags and I'm gonna get you say
that so casually but I'll go with
gonorrhea chlamydia a ratio tested okay
so then 10 I'm gonna get 10 packs of
birth control pills okay
so typically at any other doctor's
office you go in you have one visit you
have thirteen procedure codes okay but
that's not what they do at Planned
Parenthood they unbundle the service so
it looks like you came in for thirteen
separate visits then they do the
opposite for abortion so all of the
things that you have during an abortion
procedure blood pressure you know vital
signs RH testing pregnancy testing all
those they do what they should be doing
and they bundle them all together and
take all those services for one visit so
we'll never actually know the real
numbers that Planned Parenthood has they
have them but we'll never know them
because they will never give out the
number of unduplicated client
that they see every year if they did we
would see that probably about 50% of the
services that they provide are actually
coming they're actually abortion
services and why won't think about that
that list is that what's their
justification you know they just really
need people to believe that they are all
about family planning however we might
be seeing a change because their new
president dr. Leana win comes out
recently on Twitter and says hey stop
making it sound like we're all about
family planning our core mission at
Planned Parenthood is to actually
increase abortion so we might be seeing
a change with this new president maybe
one day we will get the real numbers I
went to the women's March women's
convention in Detroit two years ago and
I just wanted to sit in on the sessions
and listen and it was interesting
because we of course sat in on the plane
did you say women's March women's
convention in Detroit yes I would rather
arrive at the gates of heaven in st.
Peter's send me straight to hell for
eternity then attend that in that God
forsaken city but continue with that
story God love you for doing it so that
I don't have to so we just wanted to see
like of course we sit in the Planned
Parenthood tract which makes them very
uncomfortable because they know who I am
and so we're sitting in there and it was
so funny because the audience here
they're talking and they're taking
questions from the audience and the
audience is like they're all people that
work at Planned Parenthood so they're
all standing up saying can we please
stop saying that only 3% of our abortion
we all know that that's a lie and that's
only creating additional abortion stigma
if abortions not wrong why do we keep
saying it's only 3% as if it's a bad
thing if it was a hundred percent right
and I was like yes
so at one point in time they had these
questions answer so I decided I need to
go up and ask a question have your
picture your portrait on a wall there so
you got up to the microphone is
impressive so I wanna hear what's next
I'm at the
yes trying to cut me off they were
trying to end a session before I could
say something but I'm like so I start
talking and one of the girls that worked
there at an abortion clinic had said you
know I cry with my patients I know how
difficult this is for them she had had
she admitted to having like six
abortions and all this and so I get up
to the mic and I'm like listen I said
I'm a woman who has had two abortions
and I said and even though I'm regretful
of those decisions now I was not
regretful at the time and I said so
aren't you just escalating abortion
stigma by saying you're crying with your
patients why are you crying
it's not a baby so what are you crying
about
like what's the deal and they were all
just like oh well you know well we
should probably wrap up now but the
audience who didn't know who I was
yeah was like yeah answer the question
the question because they wanted to see
you get rag-dolled they were thinking
they would answer like no you're right
we should stop trying and you're going
on a second there's this is obviously a
logical inconsistency so I don't know
what did they kick you out sort of so
once it got around in their little page
that I was there
these clinic escorts that I think were
women may be okay because men can get
abortions - I want to ask you about that
next how the culture has changed but yes
sure
so these people came and sought me out
at the conference and they start like
getting in my face and they're like we
know who you are you're not welcome here
bah bah and so obviously like I'm not a
small gal or anything but these people
were like basically like I should
probably leave so it was at the end of
the day anyway so we've made it like
through the whole day
but once they started what was
interesting was that once it started
going around on their app that I was
there a lot of people that were there
were like why is it a problem that she's
here so what she's pro-life like she's a
woman she probably cares about some of
these other issues right why are you
giving her a hard time so it was really
sort of like a clash even among the
people who were there well I'm glad that
you made it through most of the day that
that being said I hope we didn't boot
you too close to the end of the day
because when the sun goes down in
detroit you die let me ask you well this
is something attention to me we've had I
think the last time you are on the show
a couple of years ago and certainly when
I started doing this show hosting this
program before it was daily back when I
was in Michigan and it was it was in my
den safe legal and rare was still
somewhat the mantra I remember that's
how they kind of tried to refute the
idea of Gosnell like this is an extreme
example we we need Planned Parenthood so
there is no Gosnell situation we need it
so that abortion is not that common that
it is clean than it is sanitary that we
ensure the safety of our patients and
now we've gone from safe legal and rare
to shouting your abortion would you say
that the culture in Planned Parenthood
today as you see it obvious as an
outsider is different than when you were
there or was it just hidden more
effectively yeah it's different I mean
you know when you know we performed
abortions we had abortion quotas we all
of that rape but that was sort of like
for management to know we had abortion
brochures but they were kept behind the
counter so they weren't just like out in
in public view yeah it was still more
about well we are all about women's
healthcare we're all about birth control
or about these things and yeah
occasionally we do abortion which we new
management knew was way more than
occasionally but that was sort of the
public front they would put out people
now it's so just brazen like
in-your-face everything is about vagina
an abortion and I went to the women's
March two years ago and I have this sign
that says Ernest rejected oh I think our
evil overlords that the Internet
we're silencing you a little but we
didn't get that your signal went out can
you just repeat what your sign said okay
so my my sign says true feminists reject
abortion and I said that went over like
a fart in church okay so which by the
way I've also done so I haven't
offending people in all fronts also how
we thought a man was having a heart
attack when temperatures held that
thought sweaty this is a true story I
sort of I've never prayed so hard in my
life honestly I was in church and I we
thought a man was having a heart attack
or a seizure and he was foaming at the
mouth and he fell over and like you ever
see like real serious someone's foaming
at the mouth and I was sitting I was
like please God please don't let this
man die kind of knew him it was a nice
guy
um he choked on a Mentos swear to God
that's all he was just looking for some
minty freshness so it was just it was
just white right
the pastor went from being really
concerned to very upset because he had
clearly fallen asleep during the scene
but okay sorry can continue with what
you were saying okay so I'm at the
women's March and I couldn't I mean I
was like I was looking around and I was
like I'm actually embarrassed to say
that I had been at one point I'm a part
of this movement you know they're like
we're more than our sexual parts yet
every single sign had the word put on it
okay like my favorite favorite sign was
I don't really know if I should say this
my favorite that I saw there was like a
woman's legs open okay I have a picture
of it and Trump's head was her vagina
and then her pubic hair was Trump's hair
okay and it's like trub stay
out of my [ __ ] and I'm like girl maybe
girl yeah he is not trying to be there
okay and they were even embarrassed
because I was I don't know he remember I
interviewed Wendy Davis at the Women's
March and Stephanie even when my wig and
hat blew off apparently you know the lid
hadn't been blown off the gag she still
continued the interview but during that
day if you if you watch the video
they're a bunch of topless women out
there and they actually had a peeing a
paper mache there's no other way to say
this
a giant pissing paper mache vagina
that's what they had I don't know why
urinating I don't you understand that
what fasten to its reproductive health
but that's what they had this girl was
topless and because she thought I was
transgender I had to stop because I knew
my wife would see the same when she
grabbed my hands at one point and tried
to put them on her breasts like look now
take your word for it
um but later that night she was our
server
she was our server at the pizza parlor
and she had no idea that I was Stephanie
and so I asked her so what did you do
today uh nothing I kind of checked out
the women's March said oh anything
happened there no no she didn't say I
was out there showing mics to the entire
City of Austin from the Capitol steps
and tried to give a [ __ ] the
opportunity to grasp them almost
sexually harassed a transgender with my
bare breasts she was embarrassed by it I
would imagine that also translates to
workers at Planned Parenthood when
they're trying to teach their kids it's
like mom is this hold on a second mom is
this not you with your bare Center
trainee at the women's large in a paper
mache vagina yeah you know listen I
don't know if you have the authority to
ground me so the media X is oh it's not
embarrassing but I do since there's a
bit of a disconnect from some rational
pro-abortion activists who might be
embarrassed by the shot your abortion
thing it was really vile and I'm not I'm
no prude okay but it was like really
vile and and I just thought oh my gosh
like this is not I was never part of
that movement I would have never carried
a sign that said that you know but it's
just who they become
they're really proud it's like we're not
you know they don't know who they are
right so they're like well we're we're
you know we're more than just our sexual
organs yet let's talk about my all day
and then by the way they're not happy to
oblige we're good to be a woman no it's
like what like it just doesn't make any
sense they don't know who they are
they don't all what they support how
does that compare with the the
right-to-life Marsh well I believe you
spoke there this year and it was a
pretty big one
not a peep of course from the media um
how would you contrast it to you know
strangely nice no [ __ ] signs really the
March for Life yeah I can believe it you
know it's just different the the women's
March is fueled by anger and hate and
really it's not even a women's March
it's an anti-trump March I mean let's
just be honest that's what it's about
good point you um yeah and like the
pro-lite the March for Life is like it's
just really like joyful and there's so
many young people there and you know
occasionally some Native American
protesters that nobody knew was there
and but like even the protesters that
are we go here because abortion was a
very common practice among the Apaches
sure so you know even even the
protesters are there like the poor women
that show up to be there to protest like
they're treated with kindness really but
by the pro-lifers you know when I went
to the women's March I was pregnant with
my twins I was like big visibly pregnant
with my twins and I'm holding my sign
and some these three people come and
like barrel me and like knock me over
and like assault me you know in this
three because I'm pro-life and so it's
just a very different vibe it's a very
different tone and people are just
generally more joyful right yeah I can
imagine
I did want to go to the women's March
this year speaking of vulgar displays I
like to use the system to subvert the
system a lot of Google are you telling
dick jokes right well the reason is
because I know that these people use
vulgar
and we're certainly nowhere near this is
a pg-13 show but actually that's the
language they speak and so you use it to
subvert it and effectively hopefully
transmit a message I wanted to go we
didn't have the time and I was not in
the best of health I wanted to go to the
March this year and have a big pajama
shave Ajani like they have and want to
have a big display and I wanted to be
dressed as a baby and crown and come out
but then have a doctor chase me with a
pair of scissors as a pro-life display
but I didn't have the time to do it and
I think it would have been lost on a lot
of people speaking of kindness and
compassion I think of people have read
your book and people have look into your
work that it speaks for itself it's it's
a catalog that speaks for itself I think
something that's missed by a lot of
people and this is your your latest
outreach abortion worker calm a lot of
people who work in the abortion industry
who want to get out they also have
stories they also have confliction z'
that are really hard for them to discuss
what's been your experience with that
and what are you doing with abortion
marker comm yeah so you know and then
there were none in our ministry um we
just we have almost 500 workers who've
left now and this means leaving like
Planned Parenthood in places that
provide abortion clinics yeah I think
what we didn't really expect was just I
mean such a large percentage of them
suffer from PTSD and not like how
everybody says they suffer from PTSD
like legit diagnoseable PTSD because
they see the ultrasounds they see the
ultrasounds and not only that but like
we've had a lot of workers come to us
from late-term abortion clinics and
they're telling us like about babies
that are born alive that are suffocated
to death they're you know they're left
to die crying on their own like in a
metal pan in the utility closet like
there's just a lot of there was one of
our workers that came to us who there
was a baby born alive at 23 weeks
and they would not allow her they were
physically blocking her from leaving the
the procedure room to go call 9-1-1 to
save this baby and she was doing CPR on
the baby for like 30 minutes before they
pulled her off of the baby and so
there's just a lot of like trauma
I mean piecing together baby parts
during the day that's not normal
like nothing that you do in the abortion
clinic is normal and so you know we just
I think we didn't expect like so much
trauma and so that's what we did have to
hire a licensed professional therapist
to come on staff with us because almost
all the clients that come through our
ministry like they need professional
counseling well that was going to be my
follow-up question because I know a lot
of people will say well hold on a second
you're acting like this is you know not
without my daughter and you're trying to
pull them from some country like they're
a refugee they are working at these
clinics of their own volition why do
they need you what's the average person
who comes to you for help why what are
they seeking when they say hey I need
you to help me get out of this as
opposed to walking in and giving two
weeks notice
so the abortion industry tells them that
if they if they ever leave they'll give
them a bad reference and we've seen that
over and over again they try to like
blackballed them from the medical
community if anybody calls I mean we've
been told by potential employers of
these workers when I call they gave me a
terrible reference even though they've
been like a stellar employee I think
what Clara did to me I had just been
awarded their employee of the year for
God's sake and when I left they were
like she was a terrible employee anyway
really that's why you gave me the
employee that you're okay
so it's you know we're talking about an
industry that is not known for its
honesty so they're not honest they
blackballed these workers they a lot of
the workers that come to us are single
parents they did not know that they were
gonna be doing a abortion person that
they were going to be participating in
abortion procedures because
I would say 90% of the people that come
through and then there were none we're
told oh you're not gonna have anything
to do with abortion you're just gonna be
answering phones you're just gonna be
taking the money you're just gonna be
doing labs you're just gonna be running
vitals that was all they were told they
were gonna do but what they do is they
slowly work you back
you know once you're comfortable with
abortion you get a little more
uncomfortable more comfortable then they
start moving you back into the rooms and
then like you're sort of stuck because
you're making a lot of money you have
good insurance or a single mom you're
working 50 60 hours a week when do you
have time to go get another job you
don't so they feel very trapped so
that's that's when we that's where we
can come in and help now what would be
their motivation for taking someone
who's signed up to be a desk worker and
gradually moving them back into the room
why wouldn't they just say okay you just
stay a desk worker
well the turnover rate is so high
within the abortion industry the
turnover rate something like 30 percent
I think the national average is like 18
or 19 percent and so the turnover rate
in the abortion industry is super high
so they eventually want everybody in the
office to be cross-trained like I could
do everything in my clinic except
actually perform the abortion but I
could do ultrasounds I could draw every
lab I could run every test I could do
counseling I could do billing I can do
everything they want to train everybody
everywhere because somebody is always
quitting so the the initial turnover
rate is really high and that's kind of
the reason for your your outreach your
ministry because once people are in
they've made it past that turnover rate
they tend to get in pretty deep and it's
it's hard for them to get out ready get
out
gosh that is just harrowing to imagine
how many of these women because you said
they might get bad referrals you know
they might not get a good reference is
that for the medical community at large
or if they want to go just to another
abortion clinic no it's genetical
community at large okay we had a light
we had a pro-life doctor who was willing
to hire one of the medical assistants
who had left and he said I have never
heard such a scathing reference
uh from and he said and I know I mean
they just and and that's illegal
actually what they were doing talking
about her personally
that's illegal like the only thing
you're supposed to give is like the day
they started the day they left how much
they made and if there rehire well but
this person this management went on and
on about how terrible she was and nobody
should hire her and he would be a fool
to hire this woman and all this kind of
stuff she's turned out to be an
excellent employee for this doctor but
they will do anything to keep these
workers sort of in bondage and beholden
to the abortion industries what happens
is they feel like what they can't get a
job outside of the abortion clinic
they'll be forced to come back mm-hmm
and that's really what they want and
it's like going back to a pimp who
slapped you around in the first place I
would love to know what that phone can
you and then can you if you can imagine
I would let her within a mile of any
medical facility to sterilize the
instrument
I said toss it in a toss into the
dishwasher with some dawn on fast cycle
and call it a day
she wanted us to do the pots and pans
that's 32 minutes what am i retired let
me ask you this how many of these women
who come to you obviously we're kind of
talking about just a professional
existence or they want to move on to
other work and they feel trapped how
many of them would you say go from being
pro-abortion to pro-life or are a lot of
them still pro-abortion to an extent and
they just are sort of disenchanted with
the industry no I mean I I would say
almost all of them I once they actually
go through our program and everything
all of them will come away saying like
no I'm against abortion some of them you
know they're like I'm still having a
hard time like with exception you know
like raping insects okay but none of
them would say like abortion is okay
it's acceptable it should be legal right
they see the damage that was
two women inside of these clinics and
and they want to walk away from it a lot
of them then start speaking out and we
have some women like we have two people
who worked for Kermit Gosnell Clinic who
actually went to prison for three years
for murder charges when they got out
they contacted us and they went through
our healing program so there are some
that have worked they worked in the
industry a long time ago but they just
never found healing or told anybody
about it so then they come through our
program later
so really none of them are coming
through shouting their abortion like the
RICO law guy they're they're pretty much
all defense okay we do have to get going
pretty soon so I do want to talk about
you just mentioned the the film project
I know it's unplanned film.com is the
website can you I don't want to blow the
lid off anything can you tell the
audience a little bit about that and
where they can look for it yeah so I'm
it's coming out March 29th and it's
gonna be a big wide release so it's not
gonna be like you know I have to drive
for a half hours go see this movie it'll
be everywhere and it's really good like
it's not a cheesy Christian film there's
like some kind of thing in it you know
it's it real because like I told the
directors look listen to me so you
cannot have a film about abortion
workers or people are like gee whiz did
you see that that's not reality
how many Jill occurs methinks I'm gonna
need to get some forceps this way so
it's very real girl Kirk Cameron over
there in the surgical mask in it nothing
wrong with that I'm just saying you
probably wouldn't cost you wouldn't take
part in the film that might be so raw I
like mr. Cameron not much it's very raw
and and so yeah if you know ally Stuckey
yes yes yeah yeah I know she yeah of
course she sprained it last night and
she texts me and last night and she's
like obvi she's like the reason I love
film is because a lot of times in
Christian films like the fall is sort of
like it wasn't that bad right so then
like the redemption isn't really that
big of a deal she was like but the fall
in your movie is so bad but I was so bad
if she's like it makes the redemption
even better because you see like truly
how bad things were sure and I think
that's I think that's definitely a true
assessment you know what that's what the
Bible is the truth is if the Bible were
written today there would absolutely be
cussing in there because it's a
documentation of what so if you read the
Bible I go when people say I cannot
believe it what you just said was
pornographic have you read songs of
Solomon Fabio might as well be on the
cover of that go Gary
it really is unbelievable Jesus called
people fools that was hugely offensive
back then
trigger warning fools was about as bad
as you can possibly get and I think
that's important we try to be pretty
transparent in this show even know I've
talked about my shortcomings because
yeah I again not - I don't want to rag
on any specific film but the movie
fireproof okay I say this because I
watched it and you're talking about the
fall it was about a marriage that had
some problems well the problems were the
guy watched porn every now and then not
a good thing and he was like it mad at
his wife I'm like I have holes in my
wall from what I threw a Kiwi enraged by
the way I'm even oaky we could break
drywall so I think it would help people
who are going through real problems if
you actually recognize the phone
otherwise there can't be any redemption
and that's not glorifying this and
that's not glorifying the fall it's
acknowledging that we need help
otherwise it's moot well then you have
all these people are like oh gosh well
I'm way worse than what was portrayed in
that film so is there even hope for me
let me tell you something you can't get
much worse than how I'm portrayed in
this film so it really is a movie for
everybody it's gonna make everybody feel
really good about themselves like if I'm
ever having like a fat day I watched my
600 pound life right because it makes me
feel much better about myself that's
essentially like what this movie is
you're like man I really screwed up
today just go watch unplan you'll feel
way better about
that's exactly what I did when I
ruptured my disk in in my back and I
found that I was gonna be like half an
inch shorter I watched little people big
world yeah perfect and it just provided
a little bit of context just took the
edge off that and some percocet all
right it is at Abby Johnson Abby Johnson
org and then there were none as the
ministry I think that's that's abortion
worker calm the movie is unplanned film
calm is gonna be a wide release so you
don't have to go to a men's group or a
women's Bible study what's what's the
date March what March 29 March 29th I am
definitely going to go and see that film
I'm looking forward to it because I know
I've been following that well you know
I've been following your work here for a
while and I encourage everybody else to
hey Abby thank you so much for being
here and keep up the good work we
appreciate it here I am drinking from my
mug in a button-down how often do you
see this never so do me a favor and
yourself click one of these videos
playing in one of these boxes here or a
subscribe hit the notification bell also
because subscriptions don't really mean
a whole lot if you really want to
support the show join my club if you
don't then there's no helping you